[Music]
what's up reject nation it's John coming
at you and today we're gonna have a
little fun we're gonna try something new
and and strange because the people over
at Roma that's right Troma entertainment
famous for bringing us such cinematic
gems as the toxic avenger romeo and
juliet poultrygeist Sargent kabuki man
and of course class of nuke em high
they sent us over a little trailer for
return to Nukem high volume 2 so
apparently this is the third installment
were three deep in the Neukom hai series
now and I figure why why don't we check
this out this could be fun this this is
gonna be off the walls but hey this will
bring us closer together I know it let's
let's let's just do this let's watch
this trailer in the history of cinema
masterpiece milestone of a film comes
along that changes the landscape of this
landscape
dead Star Wars guardians of the galaxy
[Music]
drama losses James Gunn of those
milestones has there been a two part of
it like this
it begins with return to nukem highball
you won I think I'm in that
[Music]
now comes the much-awaited conclusion to
avoid coffins most ambitious movie seven
years in the making
jeepers huh return to we turn to you
come on
aka volume 2
whoa a great darkness is settling on the
Tromaville it only to erect nipples high
school students and stop it
return to return to Nukem I a ka vol 2
deals with all the hot-button issues
that are relevant to teenagers today
including bullying jihad and of course
lesbianism
told by a knife or some utility of
70-year ha
ourselves for a cinematic adventure
whose glory died nah man
never see what price immortality will
they survive with this be doing
conference possible swan song
[Music]
so it refers only to you history this is
their biggest o Restless film of all
time
Wow Wow
we turn to turn to Newcombe I a ka
volume 2 is bigger than life itself but
personal and intimate enough to touch
each and every one of us
[Music]
the total organic foodstuffs contagion
which began several weeks ago in
Tromaville New Jersey has now spread to
over 200 countries
that's why Chuck
Wow we told you we turn to goodbye aks
vol to see it with someone you love or
see it with someone you won too lightly
Wow chances are there was some stuff cut
out of this trailer that you just saw so
if you want to see the full thing go go
over to traumas channel I just like the
format of their trailer has not changed
in a long time I mean like this reminded
me of a schlocky old trailer because you
know you've got the very focal narration
and then just as many crazy pulpy scenes
as you could squeeze into their utter
chaos and yeah it's one of the trailers
that has like what four or five distinct
parts three or four or five that are all
separated by the same return to return
to new like I'm just flashing back in a
very you know delightful
wacky kind of way I don't really know
quite what to say other than this looks
like a Troma movie and if that's your
jam then then by all means have at it I
think I'm in one of these I don't know
back when I was working at Fangoria we
shot something forward from a movie at
comic-con and I think it was a follow-up
to Nukem hi but I just cannot be certain
and oh boy everything you know Troma for
is in this trailer it all takes place in
Tromaville New Jersey they walk you back
through the previous films then there's
a whole bunch of slime zany behavior
crazy effects and monster stuff a lot of
boobs ain't no deal a lot of dicks no
like chaos yeah and Stanley III was
wondering I rewatched the trailer for
volume 1 just before reacting to this
and Stanley narrates that trailer and
and is in it for a minute I assume he
must be in the movie as well and I just
want to know like her he had like often
like good friends or something I feel
like that may be a piece of trivia I'm
forgetting but for you or maybe he's got
some some dirt on him that is
particularly pertinent oh yeah this
looks absolutely insane and absolutely
lucky and absolutely Troma so what else
is there to say really what's your guys
favorite Troma movie comment below hey
oh and let me let me rest in peace let
me kill mister is in this trailer and
ron jeremy got a couple of cameos of
course lloyd kaufman cuz this is trouble
I never thought I would see Lloyd
Kaufman doing like a full-on Buffalo
Bill but that's what that appears to be
and you know props to him for being so
brave and shameless all at the same time
you know I guess you do have to
appreciate Troma for knowing exactly
what they are and going hog-wild with
everything that they do in in a weird
way like if this is for you hell yeah
and there are versions of this that are
for me maybe I'll check out one of these
movies but yeah did you guys think about
this trailer comment below here give us
your thoughts and as always you can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification about to get updated every
time we review our videos our also
follow us on Stardust app link in the
description box hit us up on viewer
reviews.com as well we're working with
them now - it's a kind of like a
personalised rotten tomatos tailored to
your tastes our written reviews are
going up over there right now so check
us out there and as always guys thank
you for joining me
Cheers